los objetos y recuerdos de los cinco
años que pasaron en túnez deben caber en
unas cuantas maletas una angustia para
Oscar y su esposa estos dos marfileños
han decidido regresar a su país no
quieren seguir sufriendo los ataques y
amenazas casi diarios
en cuanto puse un pie aquí empecé a
arrepentirme al cabo de cuatro o cinco
meses francamente tengo que decirlo vine
aquí pero no estoy a gusto por ejemplo
una vez me pegaron en el autobús porque
me atreví a pedirle el cambio al
cobrador me contestó que no le había
dado dinero entonces todos sus hermanos
empezaron a pegarme en el autobús nos
han dicho que este es un país de
derechos pero nuestros derechos son
violados Simplemente porque somos negros
comentarios racistas expulsiones palizas
testimonios como el de Óscar se han
multiplicado en las últimas semanas
destacan el trato dispensado a los
inmigrantes subsaharianos por una parte
de la población tunecina
en estas imágenes amateur tomadas por
observadores de France 24 vehículos
policiales y un grupo de personas
reunidos Al pie de un edificio ocupado
por inmigrantes ilegales
este hombre identificado como el hijo
del propietario ataca violentamente a
los inquilinos insultándoles y lanzando
piedras contra el apartamento en virtud
de la legislación tunecina que ahora se
aplica estrictamente un propietario ya
no puede alquilar una vivienda o alojar
a un extranjero sin tarjeta de
residencia y los empresarios Tienen las
mismas instrucciones
Así que la situación se ha vuelto
insostenible para los subsaharianos en
situación irregular
ese día frente a la embajada de Costa de
Marfil en túnez había cientos de
inmigrantes que habían venido a pedir la
repatriación urgente a su país
mi arrendador me echó de camino a la
tienda unos tunecinos más asaltaron
estando embarazada de 4 meses
nos apedrearon y nos gritaron
marfileños váyanse
muchos pasarán la noche allí antes de
ser transportados en autobuses como este
al aeropuerto
no se tome su Regreso como un fracaso ni
mucho menos
cuando vuelvan a su país vayan con la
cabeza bien alta porque quedarse aquí
sería una vergüenza para ustedes para
los retornos voluntarios candidatos como
edwich ahora están exentos de las
sanciones por residencia ilegal
ascendían a 25 euros al mes
normalmente tengo que pagar una multa de
6 años como Estuve allí seis años es
mucho dinero no me lo podía permitir o
me iba con la oim o a través de la
embajada la crisis me facilitó el
regreso de lo contrario habría sido muy
lento
las autoridades tunecinas se han
comprometido a facilitar la organización
de la repatriaciones y al mismo tiempo
proteger a los inmigrantes subsaharianos
de cualquier forma de violencia medidas
para aliviar las tensiones que sacuden
el país desde las declaraciones del
presidente caís ayer en un discurso
denunció entre otras cosas la presencia
de hordas de inmigrantes ilegales
supuestamente responsables de la
violencia y la delincuencia en túnez
estos comentarios causaron revuelo entre
algunos sectores de la población y
fueron condenados por las ong y el
principal sindicato del país las
palabras de caídate habrían tenido el
efecto según los migrantes ya marginados
de exacerbar los malos tratos que sufren
los encontramos a miles de kilómetros en
la pista del aeropuerto de Avilán
algunos repatriados aliviados de volver
a casa entre ellos Oscar a quien
conocimos en túnez
me bajé pero ni siquiera Reconozco el
aeropuerto todo ha cambiado aquí
encuentro todo nuevo
todo nuevo
por la gracia de Dios me siento
realmente en casa estoy feliz de estar
entre mis hermanos y hermanas no tengo
nada que decir No tengo recuerdos del
resto
pasamos momentos difíciles allá
para darles la bienvenida miembros del
gobierno sus familias los repatriados se
instalan en un centro de acogida durante
tres días para recibir atención médica y
psicológica
nos complace dar la bienvenida esta
noche a nuestros compatriotas que han
decidido voluntariamente regresar a sus
hogares en Costa de Marfil tras los
desafortunados acontecimientos ocurridos
en túnez
unos 1.300 marfileños han solicitado la
repatriación
[Música]
túnez acoge en total a unos 7.000
marfileños
[Música]